by the way everybody did write in there
like the Pew beard uh we do have some
behind the scenes audio of Richard's
pube face aftermath
sorry I'm spitting so much see I should
have shaved because I have small
whiskers to take it oh it's like stuck
in his own ears
how's it look man that looks great
you have it on your nose
he had pubes it's hard to explain his
nose yeah they were just because we'll
just kind of you know whacked him in the
face with a plate of pure vacuum or a
Dust Buster around here that we could
try to clean off his
jersey with I believe pubes got stuck in
between Richard's teeth here he is
trying to brush them out in the office
bathroom
go down goddards in like weird corners
of my mouth
[Laughter]
get out pubes
now let's brush the teeth make sure
there's no Wayward pubes
stuck in my teeth or under my tongue
oh gross
this is a weird note one of Will's pubes
fell out of Richard's mouth the night
when he brushed his teeth at home and he
and he found one of Will's pubes the
next day at his home work desk oh they
were everywhere they got everywhere and
somehow all of a sudden he turned into a
neat freak he's all concerned about I'm
like when did you get so clean yeah what
else has been found on that desk one of
the Nebraska's pubes added out of my
mouth brushed those pubes right out of
my teeth
Richard told his dad he got Will's pubes
stuck to his face and the nice thing
about Richard's Dad is he doesn't lay a
trip on him he's like he doesn't seem
phased by any of it not a bit bro how
about those Chiefs
did you hear what happened to me on the
show this week no well I bet my
co-worker will Murray who's an Eagles
fan that the Chiefs would win and the
Chiefs won but I still had to get will
Murray's pubes and [__] hairs on my
face what do you mean his cubes his
balls his balls in his [__] God damn
yeah you know Chief won you still got
[__] on you yeah I hope there wasn't any
[__] in there but some of the hairs were
from his [__]
wherever I am Bob well and get this some
of the hairs went on my teeth and in my
mouth
oh no God damn did you and that reaction
from a man who eats raccoon roadkill
yeah I started to I had a bucket next to
me oh damn the Chiefs won so it was
worth it
I have a deal
yep just another day at the office all
right we'll go Chiefs Go Chief
his father doesn't ask how wait a minute
you won how did you wind up having pubes
in your mouth no nobody cares
yeah Dad I had to take pubes and ass
hair on my face ah Fiddlesticks I don't
sound right yeah and then then Sal like
came on my face not again son yeah yeah
just another day at the office Mars will
be boys I guess
foreign